and then my name is Dwayne the rock
Johnson known as the champ here doing
hahaha
and doing some interviews and I'll be
interviewing Kevin Hart alright what we
got here okay we got over some shot we
got a set right here okay what would
what type of what type of person are you
in school were you uh you know are you
jock huh ladies man nerd which one class
now how's Glasgow that's class girl back
in high school class man cuz that was
the one I was just making everybody
laugh I was the one who I would throw my
voice I would throw my boys me like hey
thing and then you know yeah that would
be that was me that was me yeah I see
that yeah yeah let's see that that's my
turn now I'm gonna ask you a question
hey okay okay okay how was it working
with with Kevin Hart
ah you know it's the the beauty the
video there's a thing there's a thing
and this thing this thing you can't it's
rich
you can't wouldn't when you get out it's
like it's like taking a let's take it
let's take a look let's same you gotta
wait you gonna pick it up nine times out
of ten you can't do a set with it that's
where we let's move EJ hey come I can
get a one of the between us all right I
don't know what it was like working with
the link right now that's what he I
can't even do it I've been talking I've
been talking with with Kevin Hart no
it's good hey talking with the big guys
yeah every talk with the big guys been
great I mean he's doing a lot of things
this is what we do we just do big things
around here what we did as a production
you you want to grow I mean you got two
guys who just they want they want the
warts he well it's hard for people to
understand the world okay it's hard for
people to understand the world but
you've got two guys who just support
each other that's the thing he's gonna
thank you Mexico
Thank You China